this is a production of Cornell
University
good morning and I would like to first
start by thanking Allah for the
invitation so and the opportunity to
talk to you about the work I do in the
lab today I'm going to focus on one of
the lines of Investigation we have in
the lab with cheese and natural products
and I'm really glad to say that because
of that meeting with the law for nitro
important Ellen was six years ago I
couldn't fight anymore and said okay
we'll work a natural products because i
thought i was going to stop working
natural products I I did some work on
metal products of my PhD and postdoc and
I'm going to mention it today but I
thought okay and that's going to be it
I'm going to move onto better than newer
things and then I'm back to network
products and I think you're very happy
that i visited at that area so just a
brief album oh but i'm going to discuss
today so i'm going to tell you about a
warning cancer stem cells specifically
what's the key Mia where leukemia stem
cells and the way I see what are the
challenges on eliminating leukemia stem
cells the compounds that we're using to
karaoke me stem cells the strategies
were using to the liberties compounds in
in animals at this point and off another
not other metal products so I would like
to begin with describing what cancer
stem cells are and to me the best
analogy to think about this plans since
we're talking about plans plans
analogy well not just plans weeks and I
guess you hear anything guys were
familiar with this view us in new york
university days i like to dream that
that's what i would like to see um so we
typically see weeds on our gardens and
they are annoying we want our guests to
be really green so what we think is the
best way to do you need that with its
come with their own within we work and
is not a good word with the lawn mower
and the grid is gone however we all know
if that that's not a solve the problem
if we don't get rid of that route that
way it is going to come back and be
there again so cancer stem cells are
pretty much the same thing are the root
of the disease is the root of the cancer
and we need to eliminate that cancer we
need to remake that route so I
specifically focus on leukemia and in
general Kim is considered a rare disease
when is compared to press a prostate
cancer breast cancer it affects about
200,000 people in the US it is estimated
that around 54,000 people would be
diagnosed with leukemia this year and
it's expected i run 24,000 people will
die of this disease so what you keep
what is the word leukemia comes from it
I would like to think I'd like to think
i would like to purchase drive
innovative system so we can discuss
period and and the blood system is
highly regenerative and twins hi it's
very fascinating because if you think
about how many cells were producing
every single day and then put this slide
just as an example because every time I
look at this lie I go wow it doesn't
matter how many times I see it but these
numbers are real just as an example 2.4
million new erythrocytes are made per
second per second as we're speaking
which is making tons and tons and tons
and tons and probably Rick sir sighs
wouldn't make me even more so neutral
field as is multiple abundant wide web
site and five billion neutrophils have
produced every hour of the day and if
you notice also the life span of these
cells is very short so to keep this
highly regenerative system you need a
very powerful cell that can maintain
this every day and this powerful cell is
will Rick known as a pluripotent stem
cell the pluripotent stem cell is a cell
that can give rise to boil the lymphoid
an adequate progenitor and myeloid
progenitor these cells has a very high
capacity of self-renewal and can give
rise to these progenitor that are more
committed to give rise to mature blood
cells and as they differentiate into the
hierarchy the ability to self-renew
decreases so you can imagine this this
has to be tightly regulated so what
happens with this regulation is mutated
or something goes wrong you stop making
mature blood cells and what happens is
immature blood cells accumulate in the
blood and and then this is what we
called or known about leukemia so
leukemia is an accumulation of immature
brats
and these are known as leukemic blast
they could be of the mileage system or
living for our karaoke so then it will
be the myeloid leukemias or the
important kamias my laboratory
specifically focuses on myeloid
leukemias so what what is the origin of
leukemia it has been hypothesized that
either a hematopoietic stem cell or n
hematopoietic progenitor will be half 12
or more of eugenic advance that will
give rise to leukemia stem cell this
leukemia stem cell also has a capacity
to self-renew and give rise to
projectors is in this case of chemically
janitors which in turn will give rise to
the leukemic blast but what I wanted to
think is not working it comes from what
I want you to think is how a true genius
leukemia is so in a single patient we
are going to have looking at last two
kami progenitors and leukemic stem cells
and the problem becomes then when you
look at the outcomes of patients with
AML acute myelogenous leukemia which is
what I would like you to focus on
because this is a big problem that's a
reserve will work on AML so maybe in the
past 40 years you can see that the
outcomes of any amount and really poor
and they have not changed at all you can
see in 1973 and 2002
they papers are pretty much on top of
each other in patients over 55 years old
so and the reason is not because the
therapy doesn't work is the reason is
because standard care works in the sense
that most patients with AML when they go
to stand their induction that will go
into remission so around eighty five
percent of patients that gets fema
therapy will achieve complete remission
the problem is that most of these
patients are going to relax very rapidly
and then die of disease so that's what
the outcomes are all over spore and
that's what the therapy has not changed
because there is nothing so far that is
better that that a five percent and the
reason we like to thank is because this
again this heterogeneity on the cells
what happens is the patient come to the
ml and then undergoes pouring standard
of care and we know that there's this
yeast left behind and we like to call
that minimal residual disease and this
minimal residual disease because we know
is there and in many cases is very hard
to detect unless we can track a mutation
and other features of that particular
leukemia but most of the cases this
still a black box but we know this this
is left behind why because the patient
relaxes we would like to think that the
reason that the patient relaxes
leukemia stem cells left behind which
again has had a capacity to self-renew
and give rise to disease so my focus is
to try to find and identify differences
between a leukemia stem cell and a
normal hematopoietic stem cell in order
to be able to eliminate leukemia stem
cells without harming your movement OBX
stem cells so stem cells can be
identified by the unified no time and
I'm here putting the mini phenotype a
newborn star during his research many
many years ago which they would pretty
much identical they will define a cd4
positive see Italy a negative hla-dr
negative so what is the clinical
implications oh yes you tell me all
these very nice hypotheses but is that
actually clinical evidence that suggests
that this population is important and
the answer is yes there is many papers
that have shown that patients that have
high proportions of cd4 positive cd8 net
negativity a negative of cells in the
bone marrow or the peripheral blood it
always correlate sleep or out of the
patients the words if they have high
proportions of this population of cells
so why would the heist and some
frequency correlate with poor outcomes
i'm going to show you the experiments we
did to demonstrate that leukemia stem
cells were resistant to chemotherapy but
before describing those experiments I
want to briefly describe the assay just
in case before I'm not familiar with it
which what we do mistake voltage clean
yourselves with retail sector
whatever drug of choice we want and we
stay in the cells for the next thing in
seven days so in a cell that is alive
and intact you'll have some positivity
phospholipid in the inner leaflet of the
membrane of the cell and then nucleus
are under the naming of European
accessible because the staff is in fact
as the Sun starts undergoing apoptosis
for its only happen if the phosphatidyl
serine is going to click to the outside
leaflet of the cell and then the next
thing can bind to that prospective
material and stay in that cell as a cell
continues the process of cell death then
the nucleus becomes available because
the cell becomes very permeable and then
seven ad which isn't a DNA died whilst a
nucleus and the cell I will know that
this how is that so we'll mark the cells
which are the next in- 780 negative as
live cells so what we observe when we
take total bond AML and treat with
cytarabine which is the drug that is
used for standard of care we see that
this report we see more than fifty
percent of the cells and actually dying
or dead so the conclusion is yes this
digital is actually working however what
happens is if we focus on leukemia stem
cell population they find a study for
positive 30 a negative population you
see these cells are in fact most of the
cells and we'll touch about this
chemotherapy and therefore are surviving
so why are they surviving when we look
at cell that the more mature define a
study for positive Terry a positive and
label them both and a proliferation
they're known as ki-67 you can see that
their self I proliferating I'm in
contrast when you look at the Kimmy stem
cells 34 positive tell you- cells most
of them are quiescent they are not
relief raining and if you think about
the chemotherapy when he was designed he
was designed on the basis that cancer
cells grow very rapidly and that the
best way to eliminate his cancer was to
block their willing to give their
ability to proliferate so this sounds
are not proliferate therefore they
cannot be eliminated by stagger of care
the target proliferating cells so that's
nice however when we compared with the
quiescence of leukemia stem cell that's
a feature that is shared with him
antibiotics stem cells so both of them
were questioned so we cannot just pick a
drug that would kill quite as themselves
because they would have normal
hematopoietic cells and as an example
i'm showing you said karate which is the
standard of care which is the worst of
all things does a pretty bad job of
killing and Kinney's themselves and does
a decent job and harmonize normal
hematopoietic stem cells so it cannot
discriminate between these two
populations and therefore is not the
good drug to tell kim is cancelled so
this was how everything started over 10
years ago and now we know more markers
that can distinguish a leukemia stem
cell from a normal hematopoietic stem
cell and they're all labeled in green
are the markers that are found in this
positive
yourself an inbred are my ad labeled the
markers that are absent indeed itself so
you can see the a good number of markers
that can distinguish and leukemia stem
cell from a woman who with the creative
stem cell and the least will keep
growing and growing however i have to
tell you the disclaimer which is these
will change in patient to patient to
patient to patient because we are all
different and leukemia stem cells are
also different occupations so the best
way to the final cleanest and cell will
be my function so when we do in the lab
is performed functional assets which
means it evaluates ability of human stem
cell or a or a progenitor cell to give
rise to project so one of these days is
the colony forming a say the colony
forming acid when it does it measures
the ability of a progenitor stem cell to
give rise to progeny in the case of
hematopoietic cells what we see will be
normal colonies and in the case of the
leukemic cell we'll see who came in
colonies and the gold standard hasta is
what we know at the scene of transplants
are saying which will measured stem cell
activity in the case of hematopoietic
cells if we inject them in an
immunodeficient mice we will see normal
hematopoiesis normal human human
Tobias's in the mouse and in the case of
leukemia what we will see is
in the mouse but the best way to prove
that is indeed a cell that has the
ability to self-renew you have to do
serial transplantation so that you
should be able to propagate the deceased
again and again and again and again and
again forever and ever if you have a
stats out so these are the essays wood
that we use in the lab so based on that
other than the next thing is can we find
molecular features that can identify Kim
in stem cell from another one with waves
themselves and take advantage of that
teacher to fill this out so we found
that feature and that feature is NF
Kappa B nf-kappa B is a transcription
factor that is involved in growth and
survival responses in tumors and the way
it works is in a normal cell nf-kappa B
would be fine inactive in the cytoplasm
of the cell and you can then take it can
be maintained in active x 18 he leader
called i kappa b alpha upon a stimuli
that could be many different types of
stimuli like infection for example in
the case of normal cells nf-kappa b i
kappa b alpha will get phosphorylated
and then degraded by the proteasome
leaving anything kappa be free we go to
the nucleus and start the transcription
of genes involved in survival
proliferation and information so that's
what nf-kappa b does so what we found
was that in cubic stem cells nf-kappa b
was constitutively activated in the
nucleus shown here by a DNA binding
assay and you can't dress normal
hematopoietic
cells do not have any company
constitutively active when we found this
first we were not surprising and if
kappa b was constitutively active in AML
because it already had been reported to
be critical for the survival and
proliferation of tours many other tours
but what actually surprised me was when
we look at the very primitive who is and
stem cells nf-kappa b was also
constitutively active so this sounds
like hyacinth are resting but yet they
have this transcription factor
constitutively on so that led us to
think and hypothesize i can we use this
unique characteristic to eliminate
leukemia stem cells can we target
nf-kappa b to selectively eliminate
leukemia stem cells without harming
normal hematopoietic stem cells so to do
this we turn to plants and we use this
compound called for cellulite which is
derived from a plant known as people
feel and it's both feverfew because it
has been used for many years to the
crispy verse as its name says and body
has other medicinal uses such as clinic
migrants and the toxic shot in stomach
eggs arthritis asthma and skin rashes
tumors insect repellent and support and
so on the many uses which pay-per-view
has been listed for in ethnobotany
chemically is a cisco drippin lactam and
it was well known to be a potent
inhibitor of nf-kappa b by now with all
the research we've done and other groups
we know that a personal life also the
pit style and has many
targets but at the time it was listed as
a very important and it kept away he
leader so we tried we found is when we
use any personal life in leukemia stem
cells shown here we saw that most of the
kidney cells from different AML patients
each line represents an AUMF patient
sample this subpoena stem cells were
eliminated with a concentration of five
micromolar of parthania light in
contrast when we look at normal
hematopoietic stem cells you can see
these cells apply micro molar
concentration were not affected by this
compound so this demonstrated the
personal life can very effectively
eliminate leukemia stem cells not having
aa not only how to create a stem cells
but this is just based by phenotype we
also put overrated these are using sorry
the functional assays that I mentioned
to you which first we did the colony
forming assays and you can see that
treatment with personal life decreased
very significantly the ability of
leukemia cells to give rise to colonies
but did not affect the ability of a
normal hematopoietic stem cells to give
rise to normal red blood cell colonies
and avoid yourself hours and more
importantly when we treated the cells
with personal ID and then transplanted
them into an inner deficient mice to
assess the function of the cells we
found a treatment important of life and
even aided
this leukemia stem cells to give rise to
Kimia but did not affect the ability of
normal hematopoietic stem cells to keep
tries to normal hematopoiesis so this
demonstrated that indeed personal life
was a very potent inhibitor of a
leukemia stem cell function we needed to
corroborate that the reason that
personal network was because our
hypothesis we wanted to corroborate that
will indeed committing a leaf kappa b so
the way which i'm going to show to you
which you seemed immunofluorescence
which in a leukemia stem cell and if
category will be active in the nucleus
and in this case would be statement he
allows you said in the nucleus and we
expect that if we keep it personal life
and if kappa we should go back to the
cytoplasm where it belongs so when we
file missing day that treatment with
personal life inhibited effectively
nf-kappa b in his leukemia cells and the
other feature that personal ideal was a
very important induction of reactive
oxygen species in this case measure with
a transcription factor known as
interactive nrf2 in a control cell will
be found in the cytoplasm but if it if
this error voice signal gets activated
it will go to the nucleus and then we
like to bake conscription and you need
personal life resulted in activation
interactive demonstrated that we seem to
send reactive oxygen species so
everything is very nice and beautiful
and we found something that can kill
Kimmy stem cell but of course personal
life cannot be used in humans as serious
why because it has very poor solubility
and bioavailability in animal studies
language use a 40 milligrams per
kilogram which is the maximum amount you
can salut belies this compound very low
amount was attacking the plasma of this
noise which was 200 nanomolar so if you
remember I told you we need at least
five micromolar to kill leukemia so this
amount will not be useful to click
animals or people so for those reasons
we started collaborating with dr. Peter
crooks to make medicinal analogue to
poor fellow white and what we found was
the nfet which is a solid all analog of
personal life and I just point out here
the timeline so it takes a long time to
go through all these brushes to make a
medicinal have analog and take it to
phase 1 clinical trials so the omega TD
is right now in clinical trials and
we're expecting to see what happened
with this compound to see if it actually
would kill leukemia stem cells
infections but I since its analytical I
will have to talk about the studies we
did in dogs because I I think this is
very interesting a very poor and I think
you guys will appreciate it more than
other people so we use can I leukemias
and I have to point out that this is not
a leukemia stem cell model this word
advances from the new cd34 positive
leukemias and at the time that we
started this collaboration with both we
suck sorry was a collaboration and was
established by chance so what happened
is we publish the paper with personal ID
will receive a phone call of a bad
and we use your comp our windows doors
have a ml and they that very rapidly
okay now there is nothing for them can
we try it so we thought I'll be cool but
we don't know anything about the
leukemias we don't even know if an if
kappa b would be active interview Kim s
so the very first thing we did is tested
epen if kappa b was constitutively
active in leukemias of the eyes and the
answer was yes so we did checked and
then the second thing well would
personalize work in this dog opinions in
vitro and the answer was yes we also
tested normal bone marrow from dogs
healthy dogs and we found that party no
light was not harmful to normal
hematopoiesis of dogs so with that he
can say okay let's do it let's try it
and we tested in three dollars so the
end is very small but I thought the
results would really be and change how
we saw personal ID for clinical trials
so work tree dogs will advance in cd4
positive leukemias we treated them with
EMA PT in different doses different
schedules because that dosent schedule
was dependent on the big day against the
door of the size of the dog and how far
the vet clinic was and and also we when
you when you would oh the pharmacology
of a DM apt in God because I was a study
that was done to take the drug to
clinical trials so we knew that a dose
of a hundred milligrams per kilogram was
the maximum tolerated dose for a dog so
in even in that sense we were lucky we
have that information so so we took
different time points
collect a peripheral blood we check the
white blood cell counts we look at c34
because was the only market that we knew
and there are very few markers available
for cross sector retreat to look at dog
cells and then we also look at our
biological markers of course nf-kappa b
and in this case to mention reactive
oxygen species or stress we use gamma
h2ax and mainly because it was reacted
with God so what we saw is first with so
an increase this is an example of one of
the dogs we saw a very marked increase
on white blood cell count after the
treatment with EMA PT 50 milligrams per
kilogram what we saw two was the
decrease in the expression of cd34
positive in this leukemia cells so this
data was suggesting to us that the
leukemia cells were differentiating
potentially to normal white blood cells
before they to take the guy and what we
have said was indeed VMA PT was causing
differentiation of leukemic cells in
vivo and of course it was inhibiting
nf-kappa B in vivo so these pieces of
evidence confirmed that indeed personal
life infinite nf-kappa B but the
surprise to us was the in vivo in dogs
p.m. apt was inducing differentiation
rather that just immediate some dead as
we sold vitro this was a major change
for how we draw the clinical trial which
is that with Don you know
good idea to first decrease the weapons
of cans of the patient because you don't
want to have tumor lysis syndrome in
people we did observe tumor lysis
syndrome in one of the dogs so this was
very lucky I think for us to be able to
fix animals and be able what happens
when you have a spontaneous leukemia
where you have dug leukemia indoor
environment which we don't see of course
in the cigarettes that that's the part
of missing when we treat xenografts
because you have human cells in Mom's
Mike environment which is not the same
as you seen people but you might want to
want you might wonder what happened
within the previous stem cells this was
the shot we took in the dark because we
don't even know if the animal if we
could do see no grasp of dollars so we
said well let's just try it the work
that can happen that nothing happens so
one maybe is themselves from day 0 of
treatment of this dog and then they
drive after treatment of the dog we
transplanted the cells equal cell number
of leukemia cells in the mouse at the
zero and in the house at from they 12
and we measure the ability of this LCD
brush to leukemia in these mice and when
we find was a significant decrease in
the ability of these leukemic cells to
congrats to leukemia in the mask but we
didn't x is to see little
transplantation like I told you yest m
cell will be able to recap you two
vertices forever and ever and ever and
what we observe is when we cheerly
transplanted these cells again equal
cell numbers for doghouse for these mice
we saw a significant decrease that the
significant decrease was even stronger
when add this the cells were serially
transplanted this data strongly
suggested that person
I was indeed targeting leukemia stem
cells are in this animal so so that that
was great and now we're just waiting to
see what happens with the clinical
trials with people and and it's still
undergoing but we expect to see similar
observations and the endpoints that
we're going to take are going to be very
similar to what we did in the doors but
this always very nice but we're still
trying to think if there is better ways
to take this compound that are not
soluble that have very poor
pharmacological properties it takes a
way to take them faster to the clinic
and closer to where leukemia stem cell
through side so leukemia stem cells live
in the bone marrow and they like to hide
on top of being human resistance and
questen they also like to hide they like
to hide in the dorsal region of the
micro update of the bone marrow where
they are also further protected from
chemotherapeutic drugs so what we find
is why we don't take personal ID as a
proof of principle and use nanoparticles
today personal life to the bone marrow
so we do pretend a life we this was in
collaboration with a high fashion he is
in houston we took this the perfect
librarian myself this myself i covered
with silicon particles and then these
particles are covered with selecting
tire october they select entire abdomen
will guide this nanoparticle all the way
to industrial region of the bone marrow
a simple like fine i selected and then
very slowly then we tell you where the
drug in that area where you can
themselves aside so before telling you
about what happened I want to compare
and contrast how we use the
nanoparticles with how we use the
soluble compound I tell you about the dr
apt so in my eyes they have life of DM
apts only 30 minutes and those that we
thought we had to use to achieve that by
micro molar concentration is 100
milligrams per kilogram so we need to
give it three times a day or a little
wash every single day and just till you
get an idea it's syringe represents of
those so I was supposed to when I was
doing this I can I can tell you that was
not fun for me or for the mice nobody
was having fun but the worst part and
i'm not going to show it here is in
another favorite already published the
DM apt in mice by itself cannot
eliminate to riverton you need to
combine it with another drug and we
think is because probably the mice
produced more thought I on and they
prevent activity of the drug to get to
the leukemic cells so if you combine
with an antique wood with entering he
would enter inhibitors you can
potentiate activity of the amenity in
vivo to kill leukemia in mice I also
show you it works and dogs without any
other stuff so I think again the biology
if each species is going to be very
important but what was very cool about
the nanoparticles is because they are
very slow release we can deliver them
once every two weeks viettel pain and
also we ordered as much as we can load
of personal life into that myself which
will represent approximately assuming
that all the personal life made it in
the animal will be two point five
milligrams per kilogram per month so you
can see it's a huge difference in dosing
so what we found is that in the
nanoparticle personal life was very
potent at eliminating total tumor burden
when compared with in my cells with
personal life or with the empty
nanoparticles we also found that was
very importantly inhibiting nf-kappa b
in people and the thing that I found
really interesting is when we measured
personal life in there in the plasma or
in the poems of these mice one hour
after those treatment with these
nanoparticles we found that there was
nothing in the plasma and everything was
in the bones just in one hour after
injecting these nanoparticles suggesting
that is not a particle were very
effective at painting personal life to
the balls we also did serio
transplantation to demonstrate that we
actually still killing leukemia stem
cells and we saw these have to pdx
meaning to primary am out samples
injected into the mice we showed that
the interior transplantation
the ability of leukemia stem cells to
give rise to disease so because all of
these part because of the reactivity of
personal life because we found it from
natural products we thought that will be
very important to start a collaboration
people don't know about plants than know
about chemical the chemical structures
they know about the spoon tripping
lactones so we started a collaboration
with the new year botanical gardens with
Cornell here with dr. Lloyd Rodriguez
and with the University of Arkansas and
this collaboration consistent finding
plants that are related for the feverfew
to find better see spoon 2p electrons
that would have similar activity to
personal life and that we can take to
the clinic hopefully in a rapid manner
and understand better what are the
critical activities of this type of
compounds so i hope to we can have more
updates as soon but this project is
advancing rapidly so just to switch
years after we talked all about c-span
Japan lactones and and personal ID I
would like to briefly mention the work
of cranberries and the reason I want to
talk about cranberries is because this
work started from a PhD student that
came from this quote well now she's
supposed aki New York but she did her
PhD here at four now her name is Lori
and wife drum and she lost her memories
it's her passion everything she does
leave some things it's cranberries and
I'll because dr. Rodriguez and strewed
she brings everything
variants I'm not exaggerating so and
we're all learning to love embarrassed
so she she came to my lab is dr.
Rodriguez mentioned her my name and she
wanted to test her extracts in cancers
so I did lead to bigger mentor and she
had cranberries I had leukemic cells and
we said let's try it's a perfect
combination and cranberries as you all
know they are well known because they
are used for urinary tract infections
and also can stimulate a new system so
what we did forgive drive total
cranberry extract different a leukemia
cell lines and this is just an example
all the leukemia cell lines were tested
and you can see that the cranberry
extract are very important and at
causing cell death in leukemia cells
there is a threshold like a lower
concentration that you can see some
cells are more sensitive than other
leukemic cells around here but the
higher you go the concentration seems to
work on alchimia cells we also fear
about Lori also purified the active or
one of the active compounds of the
cranberries known as a packs which are
formed from different working like
multimers is not purify is not a
purified compound is a mixture of
denver's primer sacraments and phantom
errs and we have also found that
individual components are not sufficient
to kill them kill yourself so this
mixture we use at lower concentrations
in primary samples and leave the colony
assays and you can see that at 62.5
micrograms
we can see that leukemia progenitor cell
activity is decreased a normal activity
of hematopoietic cells is not affected
we have also done the stem cell acids
with skulls and we see selectivity
against leukemia stem cells not normal
hematopoietic stem cells and because we
wanted to see if she can because she
really really wanted to try it in vivo
sorcerer well described so we set up
some scene of grass we transplanted
primary patient samples in mouse we
establish the sinner graph the xenograft
anymore had leukemia she treated it with
PBS psych jargon or a pact at 25
milligrams per kilograms to turn the
week treat the era for three weeks and
what we found is that a flags were
really important at eliminating a tumor
cell engraftment almost at the same
level as rs.c so this is the standard of
care 60 milligrams per kilogram which is
very toxic to demise as in contrast 25
milligrams per kilogram which it was not
toxic to the animals so this suggests
that this primary extracts could be used
in in vivo to cure leukemia and pop
kimia stem cells these secondary
transplants are on their way so
hopefully we can also show that kills
and Kayla stem cells so just to
summarize what we discussed today is
that compounds derived from medicinal
plants such as per 1000 live and
cranberry extracts can be used to target
leukemia stem cells also the
nanoparticles represented strategy to
delivered compounds with poor
pharmacological properties into mice and
potentially also to humans and other
natural products are currently being
studied to target leukemia stem cells in
general what we're doing in the lab is
trying to get a Amen samples of
characterizing well probation patient to
hide you put assays to evaluate the
ability of compounds to kill a king a
stem cells using functional assays and
also the value of our biomarkers so we
can match the drug with a patient and
also from the bedside to the bench when
we start the clinical trials we like to
save samples character like them well by
bone marrow printer blood plasma so we
can do biological assays to determine if
we're targeting leukemia stem cells in
the patients and also test the
biomarkers to make sure that the drug is
doing what it's supposed to do and use
finally add me to thank the people that
have been working so hard on these
projects it's pre first I want to thank
my collaborators in the clinical side
specially dr. david ramos with the
director of the Leukemia program and
courtney up dr. michael bollocks our
collaborators at the new year for
technical
being getting us a lot of plans michael
Baker at the University of Rochester he
revises also leukemia leukemia cells
Peter crooks and says a compadre work on
the modification of compounds and the
purification of the compounds from plans
this is my lab in the summer it looks bc
in the summer we get a lot of people
students high schoolers and undergrads
it's a lot of fun and this is the team
so this is Laurie Sabrina and Bernardo
were the five grand team meaning they
work with a fax and cranberries and they
named their sales background and they
had a logo which was little penguin
shaped like Backman ship cranberry
eating Phineas themselves so and then is
Gabby Rachel she's actually student
heretofore not from cornell whittaker
bowel ashes from ecuador maria and yes
the missing one first up gabby but she's
not in this picture they are from the
weed steel they put in come up with a
better name but that means that they
focus on the plants like people few and
although there are medicinal plants
we're getting from our the new york
botanical gardens and this is the
funding that of course without funding I
would be doing nothing for just thinking
about it and thank you for your
attention
I mean any person or anything with
themselves to see if anything's haven't
met Kathy
with personal life I did so and we found
many other personal life like on balance
using the gene expression signature of
leukemia and the strongest signature is
a division of nf-kappa B an activation
of reactive oxygen species we've also
done modifications of personal life with
biotin so we can pull down its targets
so when we did that we found that
personal life has all their targets that
I involving metabolism and that was
recorded by my previous mentor great
Jordan and other people have also found
that can also affect epigenetic
machinery so in general / tell you life
will bind to any broad thing that would
have a preseason or any type of loop
that is available so it is not just an
NF Kappa B inhibitor who use it because
of that feature but it causes many more
things
what is the mechanism for the
nanoparticles to move them
why
so it is it is label on the surface of
the nanoparticle with a diesel ecting
thyroid reversers a very tiny peptide
that can buy be selected so in selecting
is expressed in the endothelium and is
found in very high amount into the
filium of the bone marrow so that's how
it's guided there so it's really cool
but it's very expensive so we're trying
to find other ways to take them right
there
so the BP amt studies in the canine
model then induces differentiation so in
AML then of course I mean
differentiation induction therapy has
been remarkably ineffective so those are
really exciting results and I was
wondering if you've tried or if anyone
has tried to look at you know how the
TPA and he works Cain I'm it doesn't I
presume working and human primaries yet
I know I mean that would be very nice
but at the time you know Oh everything
happened so fast like really so fast
that the amount of self we had it was
not a lot but I mean thinking back yes
we even discussed this at some point
which put Greg you would be nice if we
had blood cells left over to see what
happened to the cell when its signature
in the doghouse but first of all we had
no experience with dogs we don't know
anything about dogs we were just working
with the with these three animals so i
think i just i was talking to Christy
yesterday I think it's a great
opportunity to work and with dogs and
try to understand more about the biology
of these compounds in a system where
hopefully will be more similar to humans
hopefully maybe at least closer than my
eyes
zeno grass is it an HR like and I don't
know it might be interesting though it
can potentiate say retinoic acid
yeah and the thing is because we saw
this effect in God's not in my eyes so
even in the mind when we combine with
the entering he returned we saw very
significant energy in demise in
xenograft we never saw differentiation
ourselves in mice so so the system Brown
is so important to consider and we never
went back to the studies in dogs so you
mentioned that different patients have a
different subset of phenotypic walk is
does that change with treatment with a
fennel I door so that's a very good
question for any chemotherapy so we
really don't know and part of the
efforts to try to avoid minimal residual
disease in involves flow cytometry
because if you think about tracking a
population we need to know how this
population behaves and we cannot assume
that the markers are not going to change
my personal point of view I like to see
the final tipping markers as your dress
as your code you decide to wear
something today maybe because your gene
expression told you to but it doesn't
mean that after you get exposed to some
very aggressive chemotherapy and you
want to hide from this therapy maybe
your dress also got a change so that's
something we want to understand and we
have very strong efforts following an
understanding me montecito of the Seas
after any chemotherapy because probably
is going to be different from patient to
patient and from therapy
but if we can tell what is abnormal then
would be a way to track those cells form
a comment on secretarial a code review
well back there almost said it was two
thousand of them know quite diverse in
memory of the ester AC is up on Frankie
and with one oven gives me the Nobel
Prize or typically kids going to forget
it this lactones are we don't understand
how they go about it but there are
certain powerful force of the molecule
that we everything attached to protein
but it was still very far from the green
understanding mechanistic action is kind
of on so they're over to be proud kind
of the worst date I like what you've
done this is what we have to do with a
dictum that's already kind of a natural
product they were trying to push and
utilize it it's a pharmaceutical we
really good rigorous essays and some
fortune you will do a lot of natural
products that I think it well then maybe
these for natural products that would
take
so that I mean that's the goal of the
big collaboration with all this
multidisciplinary team who said together
because also I mean I didn't mention it
but when I was supposed to I tried many
differences when tripping like tones
just because we said always try anything
that we saw that looked like personal
life and all of the activities were very
different and when we were screening the
the medicinal analog they all behave
differently so the idea is to try to
find the most potent is going to be like
terms that are still selective and try
to understand where the selectivity
comes from because probably the targets
are not going to be the same and maybe
we will be able to delegate has to be
nf-kappa B and what else what is the
right combination of the suspension
lactams says that my collaborator you
know says that he likes to see it as a
melody he says it like playing the piano
you have to hit the right keys in order
to produce music and so we want to find
what that music is for this when you pin
lactones and leukemia their hands of the
workers
reflect multiple pants for development
of the
differences in money
I think we don't know yet and I think
the more we are doing sequencing and
trying to match sequencing to to reach
individual patient we might be able to
understand a little bit more and also I
mean anything one-dimensional the
government not to make everything some
more complicated because you are all
gonna get operated press after all this
information is that there is a lot of
heterogeneity even be we think they had
regenerate their taught you in the tumor
this is still clone of heterogeneity
meaning within the same patient you're
going to have several clones with
different mutations so what I think
about writing team IAM chemists
themselves we're playing the game wacom
white ball you hit one and the other one
comes out of you and we just going to
point a huge hammer to get them all down
so so this is this is a problem and
probably it's also like a Trojan
anything that you have in the genotype
that will be reflected in phenotype and
because all of this is evolving so
rapidly maybe will very soon have enough
information to match then the search
surface signature with that some genetic
signature and will help us distinguish
them one from the other yes is there any
possibility that when you do the serial
transplants that because everything is
so rapidly evolving that like
like a leukemia cell that's not a stem
cell can gain more stem cell-like
properties and kind of light via founder
for the disease even though it wasn't
originally the leukemia stem cell or it
was coming from or is that not something
that really happens so this is a
hypothesis that people have thought but
not on in the mouth also in people so
that's what when I told you about the
origin of leukemia is thus a hypothesis
we don't know what is the directionality
of the cells which so the definition of
a leukemia stem cell does not mean it's
a cell that came from a normal stem cell
is a cell that acquired the ability to
behave like a stem cell so could have
been a more mature between a blast but
the right combination of genetic
modifications for epigenetic
modification gave them the capacity to
cell renewal and give rise to project so
yes the morgue and actually their
studies that have shown the more
aggressive the tumor becomes even in
patients so if you take a patient at
diagnosis and separate c34 positive
severe a negative cells you can see the
hierarchy as I described to you works
beautifully the stem cells are the stem
cells and then you have the question etc
etc if you'd examine from a relapse
patient the same patient at relapse and
take the different c34 positive period
that a negative and then other cells
every cell will behave like a stencil so
the hierarchy is not month in that case
meaning that chemotherapy must have
changed something in the process so
that's why we think
really gajan Hills health from the
beginning or when they are quiet zone
before they come back once they come
back to the different monster I think
it's a question and they somebody isn't
real so okay thank you very much thank
you this has been a production of
cornell university on the web at cornell
edu